thanks to kiwico for supporting this
episode of journey to the microcosmos
click the link in the description for 50
off your first month of any crate
these little moving domes are a ciliate
called corona pediculous
that's corona with a ke not
corona like the beer or the virus
these are much cuter especially as they
climb
up and down these stalks like it's their
own personal jungle gym
but it's not exactly a jungle gym open
for the public
just ask this nopolis oh
wait you can't because those stocks
are the tentacles of a hydra and getting
close to them
was the last mistake this nopolius ever
made
this isn't our first time diving into
the world of hydras
but there were a lot of details about
them we could only talk about before
we couldn't actually see them but now
with the upgrades we've made to our
microscope there's a whole new world
inside of hydras for us to see
like these nuclei lying inside what
we're pretty sure
are stem cells which are the source of
hydra's incredible regenerative
capabilities
and not only are they constantly giving
birth to new
cells inside the hydra they may have
also given birth to the field of
experimental zoology
in the 18th century in 1744
the scientist abraham tremblay
immortalized hydra in our collective
scientific knowledge
when he published his book memoir
possible
if you like me have not studied french
in more than a decade
that translates to memoirs concerning
the natural history
of a type of freshwater polyp with arms
shaped like horns
yes what we call tentacles today were
once called
horn-shaped arms but in french so
it sounded elegant
[Music]
trembley was not the first person to
describe hydra
for you frequent viewers you probably
won't be surprised to hear that
leeuwenhoek got there before him but
when tremblay first saw his so-called
polyps
he didn't know what they were he thought
they were a plant because they were just
sitting there
their horn-shaped arms waving like
branches
attached to a stationary body and what
seemed to further support his argument
was the fact that different polyps had
different numbers of arms
and that might not seem striking to us
but
think of the animal species you know
barring any sort of injury or disease
we think of our cats all having four
legs
ants all having six legs and so on
but plants can have different numbers of
leaves and branches
even when they're the same species
[Music]
tremblay decided to see if there were
any other plant-like qualities to these
polyps
and so he cut one in half he figured
that if those cut halves grew back out
that was one more check in the plant
column
and so it didn't surprise him when he
saw the haves regenerate
it was kind of like using plant cuttings
to propagate new plants
it's very cool but also not out of the
ordinary
in the world of plants so it was
weird when he saw his supposed plant
catching some prey
including a millipede that got tangled
up in the hydra's arms
and not only were the polyps capturing
prey they actually
seemed to move around on occasion which
meant that this polyp wasn't a plant
after all
it was an animal and so that meant that
the regeneration tremblay had observed
was actually quite out of the ordinary
in fact
it ran contrary to the initial
assumptions that had driven tremblay to
bisect his polyps to begin with
the assumption that only plants could
regenerate
if the hydro was an animal and the hydra
could regenerate
then yeah it looked like some animals
could regenerate too
and going beyond the spectacle of
regeneration
tremblay had found an animal that could
make more of itself
without having to mate we know that
hydras aren't the only animals that can
reproduce asexually
they're not even the only animals that
can regenerate
but tremblay's observations were novel
at the time he made them
and our subsequent knowledge is built on
his observations and techniques
and that's why some scientists argue
that tremblay's work
marked the foundation of experimental
zoology
if you think about it at every turn of
tremblay's discovery
lies the hydra's tentacles when he
decided to cut the hydra in half
it was because of the discrepancies he'd
found when counting their tentacles
and when he later rejected his own
hypothesis that the hydras were plants
it was because he saw their tentacles
capturing prey
when you look at hydras their tentacles
are probably the main thing that stand
out because
otherwise for an animal they're quite
simple
they're basically a bag with streamers
attached
and yet despite that simplicity hydra
are very good at
catching prey and also very good at
not becoming prey and that is all due to
the power of their tentacles and the
special cells inside of them
called pneumatocytes again thanks to our
microscope upgrades
we can see those pneumatocytes more
clearly than we have before
and we can even make out the special
vesicles inside of them
called pneumatocysts which discharge at
incredible acceleration to punch through
targets
when activated the pneumaticists aren't
just for punching though
they're also loaded with a paralytic
venom that can be fatal
as this snopley is here is experiencing
[Music]
if this all sounds and looks kind of
brutal
it is but it's also kind of elegant
if you take a closer look you can see
that some of the pneumaticists start to
look
a little bit different from each other
that's because hydra have four different
types of nematicists
each with their own job stenitils for
paralyzing prey
desmond memes for ensnaring it
holotrichus isariza for protecting
against predators
and atricus isoriza for helping the
hydra cartwheel around the micro cosmos
nematosis are multifunctional powerful
and also very rare so rare that they're
restricted to the phylum cnidaria
which in addition to hydra also includes
jellyfish
and sea anemone that doesn't stop
other animals from trying to get some
pneumaticists of their own though
one species of flatworm is known to not
only get past the hydra's pneumaticist
defenses
they'll kill the hydra and steal those
pneumaticists for themselves
decking themselves out in the molecular
artillery of their deceased prey
so if the pneumaticists are so deadly
and the hydra tentacles are so full of
them
how do ciliates like corona pediculus
survive in this chemical
and physical minefield well
we don't know corona pediculous aren't
immune to the toxins in the
pneumaticists
so they must somehow be sidestepping the
issue altogether
but we don't know how they do that now
it's possible that the hydra are simply
allowing the corona to live on their
bodies
you see they're not exactly trigger
happy with their nematocysts
they do have some level of control here
to make sure the pneumaticists are
deployed correctly
some of those controls make hydra more
effective hunters
for example while pneumatocytes respond
to physical stimulation if there's a
chemical hint to prey nearby
the amount of physical stimulus needed
to activate the stenotils and desmonines
goes down getting hydra on the alert and
ready to attack
anhydra must also have some way to
distinguish between predator
and prey because they're able to turn
off their defensive pneumaticists
while capturing their next meal plus
if the hydra has caught something some
of the extract from their food
will actually turn off the locomotive
pneumaticists
to keep them from moving away during
their successful
stationary hunt so clearly the hydra has
ways to regulate its pneumatocytes and
maybe the corona is taking advantage of
one of those mechanisms
maybe the hydra is too we don't know
but for the corona i guess it doesn't
matter
instead of being targeted by the
pneumaticists the ciliates are
protected by them too as they scavenge
food from the surface of their gracious
host
and so the corona pediculus climbs and
climbs
not knowing what a deadly horn it
ascends
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you again to kiwiko for
supporting this episode
kiwi co creates super cool hands-on
projects for kids
that make learning fun they have eight
subscription lines
each catering to different age groups
and topics and each box is designed by
experts and tested by kids
and with a kiwi co-subscription each
month the kid in your life will receive
a fun
engaging new project that will help
develop their creativity
and confidence with their tinker crate
intended for kids 9 and up
your little one can put together this
really cool color mixing led
crystal that will teach them how to use
red blue and green leds
to explore mixing colors of light so
they can make whatever color crystal
they want
so if you want to keep the fun and
learning going all year long
head on over to kiwico.com journey50
or click the link in the description for
50 off your first month
of any crate the people on the screen
right now
they're our patrons if you like what we
do here these are the people to thank
and if you would like to become one of
them you can go to patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss
you can check out jam and germs on
instagram or
pick up his new book the hidden beauty
of the microscopic world
and if you want to see more from us
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere
nearby
you